elon musk founded neurolink in july of
with the extremely ambitious goal of
successfully creating a bridge
between our brains and computers from
helping paralyze individuals
to potentially downloading information
into our brains
neurolink promises to revolutionize the
way we think
work and progress forward but aside from
a few presentations here and there
we haven't heard much about the
company's progress so
what happened to neuralink
[Music]
well starting off though neurolink has
several applications in our day-to-day
life
elon musk emphasized that the primary
goal of neurolink is to quote
solve important brain and spine problems
with the seamlessly implanted device
in other words the primary goal of
neurolink is to help with neurological
medical conditions
as opposed to transforming our brains
into supercomputers
though that may happen as a byproduct
elon musk believes that
nearly everyone has some degree of
neurological shortcomings
especially as we age this may be as mild
as degrading vision
and hearing or as serious as paralysis
and brain damage
however despite the extent of this
neurological damage
at the end of the day all the signals in
our brains are just electrical signals
so theoretically fixing these electrical
signals should resolve many of the
affirmation issues
and that's basically the foundation of
neurolink
with that being said let's take a look
at what neurolink has developed thus far
starting with the implant originally the
implant was designed to sit behind your
ear
kind of like a hearing aid but this
summer
neurolink updated the implant to sit on
the top of the skull
by making this transition neurolink is
able to eliminate the wires that run
from the device to the entry point into
the skull
aside from this if you have decently
sized hair no one will even know you
have an implant
dota device is only 23 millimeters by 8
millimeters
it is said to have 1024 channels per
link which is 100 times better than
similar neural devices
musk claims that the current device is
capable of several simple biometric
tasks
such as reading blood pressure and
temperature in the future however
he hopes to expand the features to be
able to detect potential heart attacks
and even strokes moving on to how one
would actually get the implant
the process is actually quite simple as
it's all completed by high precision
surgical robot
nonetheless for most of us this is still
a very scary idea
the neurolink n1 implant contains up to
3072 electrodes per array
which is spread across 96 threads each
of these electrodes is thinner than one
hair follicle
so the procedure shouldn't be too
intrusive musk believes that general
anesthesia
is sufficient and that the implant will
be an outpatient operation
anyways during the surgery the robot
will skin your brain in order to
circumnavigate blood vessels
and it will essentially poke the
electrodes into your brain in the
appropriate places
the robot is capable of inserting 6
threads per minute
and considering that each implant has up
to 96 threads
the operation itself could take as
little as 16 minutes
but really no more than half an hour to
1 hour
once the implant is up and running all
of the data it collects can
actually be exported through a usb-c
cable now
what's actually really interesting is
that the usb-c cable isn't a bottleneck
as you might expect
our brains receive an astounding amount
of information every single second
with some research suggesting that our
brains receive 11 million bits of data
every single second from our senses
mostly from our eyes
however our brains are extremely
efficient at compressing
all of this incoming data in fact the
same research suggests that
11 million bits of incoming data is
compressed down to less than 50 bits
moreover the n1 implant is only reading
a very
very small portion of the neural
activity occurring every second
so a usb-c cable shouldn't run into any
problems
anytime soon anyways once the surgery is
complete
maintenance is pretty simple just charge
the implant every night
using a provided magnetic charger though
it might be weird to attach a charger to
your head
every night that's all cool and all but
all of that is theoretical
how much progress has the n1 implant
actually made
well the latest update we got from
nerolink was the pig demo we saw
over the summer during the demo elon
musk walked us through a state of three
pigs
the first pig did not have an implant
and he was basically a control as to how
a regular
happy healthy pig behaves as for the
second pig
at that point the pig had had the
implant for about two months
and the pig was shown to also be happy
and healthy though
it wasn't interested in cooperating at
the start
using the second pig the team showcased
how the neurolink implant was able to
sense streams of incoming information
by playing a beeping sound every time
the pig senses were provoked
moving on to the third pig this pig was
also more of a control pig
that showcased that the implant could be
safely removed without any damage to the
pig's health
in addition to showcasing that the
implant could be removed
this demonstration also showed that one
could upgrade their implant
if they so desired after the live demos
with the three pigs was completed
elon musk presented us with the video of
a pig with an implant
walking on a treadmill the video reveals
how the data from the implant
is able to quite accurately predict
where the four legs of the pig were
heading
after the demos elon must start to
discuss the possibility
of using neurolink to not only read
brain activity but
also right to the brain he details that
there are three major requirements that
must be met
before actually implementing such a
function the first of which being
precise control of the electric
field the brain is no doubt a very
sensitive organ
and as a result any current that is
being stimulated into the brain
should likewise be quite precise on top
of this
any sort of stimulation device should
not only be precise
but also have the ability to output a
wide range of different currents
our brain controls a variety of
different activities each and every
second
and different activities require
different levels of stimulation
for instance sprinting is not going to
require the same amount of stimulation
as blinking and even if a given device
is capable of both of these functions
the impact of the brain stimulation must
be monitored over a long period of time
in order to ensure that it doesn't
create any lasting damage
with that being said neurolink has made
some progress in this realm
as well in this same presentation elon
musk uses a two-photon microscopy
to show off how the implant can
stimulate brain activity
though he does showcase how the implant
can stimulate various portions of the
brain
the subsequent reaction to stimulation
was not shown
likely because the stimulation was so
subtle that it didn't cause any
noticeable physical reactions
such as like jerking or something like
that as you can see
the technology is still very much in its
infancy
but the n1 implant did receive fda
breakthrough device designation
in july and consequently they're looking
to move over to human clinical trials
as quickly and safely as possible
initially
after the safety of the device is proven
the goal is to conduct clinical trials
using individuals who are quadriplegic
and paraplegic as the demo on the
treadmill showed
that n1 implant can be used to predict
the path of the pig's limbs
if this technology can be transferred
over to humans as well
the neurolink team hopes to understand
what a person wants to do with their
limbs
just by reading their brain activity if
they are able to successfully accomplish
this
then a potential idea is to place
another implant at the base of the
spinal cord
which can relay the individual's desired
actions to their limbs
thus bypassing their paralyzation there
are actually similar devices out there
already
that accomplish such functions for
instance there are actually several
prosthetic arms and legs
that utilize the nerve endings that are
still intact to control the prosthetic
but of course this requires that the
nerve endings are still intact
and working nonetheless these
prosthetics showed that
it is possible to read neural activity
and translate them into appropriate
robotic actions
thus nerolink's plan is actually not
that far off
and we may see them succeed in helping
paralyzed individuals
within the next decade or two at the
same time
neurolink also plans to translate this
technology to other bodily organs
for example by getting a better
understanding of how the brain reads
and processes vision and hearing the
neuralink team
may be able to restore vision and
hearing or
even use cameras and mics in the place
of one's eyes and ears
though there is still a very long way to
any of these applications
these are the more realistic outcomes
that could potentially be reached within
the next few decades
but what about the crazy sci-fi stuff
that musk has into that here and there
like if you can't beat them join them
despite that apparently being the
mission of the company
at this point in time they're really not
pursuing anything crazy
like creating virtual reality using
neuralink or providing us with super
computer level computational power
they are hopeful that one day they or
some other similar company
will be able to provide such super
powers but in the meantime
they're just planning on sticking into
reversing impairments and that's what
happened to neuralink
do you guys think musk's vision with
neurolink is possible
or is it just some blown out fantasy
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys are excited
but
also scared about such technology and of
course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you